ils ont perdu leurs amis et viennent lui
rendre hommage ses proches déposent des
fleurs à l'endroit même de l'accident la
victime un jeune garçon de 16 ans tu
roules et en scooter sur cette route
quand il a percuté une voiture
cet ami l'accompagné lui aussi à deux
roues au moment du choc
il se trouvait à quelques mètres à peine
auclair et une raison que la démo est
l'invasion commence à avancer pour toi
c'est réflectivité s'arrêter le casque
du jeune garçon en scooter projeté à
plusieurs mètres témoigne de la violence
de l'impact la voiture elle ne se serait
pas arrêté tout de suite mais plus loin
dans le virage à son bord un gardien de
la paix d'une trentaine d'années qui
travaille à l'école de police de sens
l'homme n'était pas en service au moment
de l'accident il a été soumis à un
dépistage d'alcoolémie qui s'est révélé
positif
placé d'abord en garde à vue au
commissariat le policier est ensuite
transféré à la gendarmerie qui récupère
la sphère le parquet de sens en effet
choisi de dessaisir la police de l'anc
est l'amie de la victime principal
témoin de l'accident est entendu ce
matin par les gendarmes
quant aux mises en cause le policier
conducteur de la voiture ils pourraient
être déférés par la justice à l'issue de
sa garde à vue